Hi, this is Caitlin Luna, host of Speaking of Psychology. This podcast was recorded live during the 2018 APA convention in San Francisco. This episode is about how our memories may not be as reliable as we'd like to think. As always, we want to hear from you, so please email me at K-Luna at APA.org. If you have any comments or ideas for us, that's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-D-Rg. I'm joined by Dr. Elizabeth Loftus, a distinguished professor of the University of California, Vine. Dr. Loftus is well known for her research on human memory, notably false memories. Dr. Loftus has been honored by APA's review of general psychology as one of the 100 most eminent
嗨，我是凯特琳·卢娜，《心理学谈话》的主持人。这个播客是在旧金山2018年APA年会上现场录制的。本期节目探讨的是我们的记忆可能并不像我们想象的那样可靠。和往常一样，我们希望听到您的反馈，请发送电子邮件至 K-Luna@APA.org 联系我。如果您有任何意见或想法，网址是 K-L-U-N-A-A-A-D-Rg。与我一同出席的是加州大学欧文分校的杰出教授伊丽莎白·洛夫图斯博士。洛夫图斯博士因其对人类记忆、尤其是虚假记忆的研究而闻名。洛夫图斯博士被APA的《普通心理学评论》评为20世纪100位最杰出的心理学家之一。欢迎您，洛夫图斯博士。谢谢。很高兴今天能邀请到您。我的荣幸。所以您的研究告诉了我们一些我认为关于我们大脑令人不安的事情，即我们的记忆并不是一成不变的，它们基本上容易受到操控。那么您能多解释一下这一点吗？我和其他从事类似工作的人所展示的事情之一是，一旦你有了某种经历并将其记录在记忆中，它并不会以某种原始的形式停留在那里，你知道的，等待像录音设备一样被播放出来，而是新的信息、新的主意、新的想法、暗示性的信息、错误的信息，会进入人们的有意识认知中，并导致记忆的污染、扭曲和改变。这就是我在过去几十年里一直在研究的事情。
psychologists of the 20th century. Welcome, Dr. Loftus. Thank you. It's wonderful to have you here today. My pleasure. So your research tells us something I would think is unsettling about our minds, that our memories aren't set in stone, that they're basically subject to manipulation. So can you explain that a bit more? One of the things that I and other people who do similar work have shown is that once you have an experience and you record it in memory, it doesn't just stick there in some pristine form, you know, waiting to be played back like a recording device, but rather new information, new ideas, new thoughts, suggestive information, misinformation, can enter people's conscious
人类的记忆又如何被操纵呢？当人们在某些犯罪事件结束后交谈时，这些犯罪事件可能是他们两人都目睹过的，记忆就会被操纵。当调查人员对他们进行审讯时，记忆也会被操纵，调查人员可能带有某种目的或关于可能发生的事情的假设，并甚至在无意中将其传达给目击者。人们在看到关于某个事件的媒体报道时，记忆也会被操纵。假设这是一个备受瞩目的事件，电视或报纸上有很多关于它的讨论。在所有这些情况下，都有可能让新的信息，不一定是准确的信息，来污染一个人的记忆。是什么让你对这项工作感兴趣的？哦天哪，我几十年前就开始对研究记忆扭曲感兴趣了。作为一名研究生，我做过一点关于人类记忆的工作。
awareness and cause a contamination, a distortion, an alteration in memory. And that's the kind of thing that I've been studying for the past many decades. And how can human memories be manipulated? They can be manipulated when people talk to each other after, let's say, some crime is over that they may have both witnessed. They can be manipulated when they are interrogated by an investigator who, maybe has an agenda or has a hypothesis about what probably happened and communicates that to the witness even inadvertently.
后来当我拿到博士学位后，我想做一些具有更直接实际应用的工作。所以我想，嗯，我对记忆有所了解，但研究一下事故、犯罪和其他具有法律相关事件的目击者的记忆怎么样？所以我把对法律问题的兴趣与人类记忆的一些专业知识结合起来，产生了这一系列的工作。你能把我们带回到20世纪90年代初，当你谈到记忆战争时吗？那么那个时代是什么样的，发生了什么？哦，天哪，在90年代甚至可能是80年代末，我们开始看到一种完全更极端的记忆问题。一些患者去看治疗师，也许他们有焦虑症，或者也许他们有饮食失调，或者也许他们抑郁了，他们最终会遇到一个治疗师，治疗师会说类似这样的话，嗯，我见过的很多有你这些症状的人在小时候都受到过性虐待。
People can be manipulated when they see media coverage about an event. Let's say it's a high publicity event that is talked about a lot on television or newspapers. In all of these cases, the opportunity is there for new information, not necessarily accurate information, to contaminate. a person's memory. And what got you interested in this work? Oh gosh, I got interested in studying memory distortion many decades ago. As a graduate student I'd done a little bit of work on human memory.
然后就会开始这些活动，导致这些患者开始认为他们记住了多年来遭受的残暴虐待，据称他们将这些虐待遗忘到了潜意识中，直到这个治疗使他们意识到了这一点。在许多情况下，这些人起诉了他们的父母，或者让他们的前邻居、医生或老师等人，根据这些压抑记忆的指控而被起诉。
And then once I got my PhD I wanted to do some work that had a more immediate practical application. And so I thought, well, I know something about memory, but how about looking at the memory of witnesses to accidents, crimes, and other legally relevant events. So I kind of combined an interest in legal issues with some expertise in human memory and produced this line of work. Can you take us back to the early 1990s when you talk about the memory wars? So what was that time like and what was happening? Oh, gee, that, well, in the 1990s and even in maybe the late 80s, we began to see an altogether more extreme kind of memory problem. Some patients were going
所以这场战争实际上是关于人们是否能够承受多年的残酷虐待，将其放逐到潜意识中，完全没有意识到这些事情发生过，然后以后又能可靠地恢复所有这些信息。这就是为什么它如此具有争议和争论。而你的工作本质上驳斥了这一点，即这不一定是可能的，或者也许揭示了这一点。嗯，我的工作实际上提供了一个另一种解释。如果这没有发生，这些报告可能从何而来？
into therapy, maybe they had anxiety, or maybe they had an eating disorder, or maybe they were depressed, and they would end up with a therapist who said something like, well, many people I've seen with your symptoms were sexually abused as a child. And there would begin these activities that would lead these patients to start to think they remembered years of brutalization that they had allegedly banished into the unconscious until this therapy made them aware of it. And in many instances, these people sued their parents or got their former neighbors or doctors or teachers, whatever, prosecuted. based on these claims of repressed memory.
所以我的工作表明，你可以在人们的脑海中植入非常丰富、详细的虚假记忆。这并不意味着被压抑的记忆不存在。被压抑的记忆依然可以存在，虚假记忆也依然可以存在。但是对于这种大规模压抑的想法，实际上并没有任何强有力、可信的科学支持，然而这么多家庭却被我所说的这种毫无根据的指控给毁灭了。顺着你刚才的话，你说你曾一度被一个声称她的母亲对她进行性虐待的女性起诉。在这种情况下，你相信母亲没有进行过这种虐待。
So the wars were really about whether people can take years of brutalization, banish it into the unconscious, be completely unaware that these things happen, and then reliably recover all this information later. And that was what was so controversial and disputed. And your work essentially refuted that, that it's not necessarily possible, or maybe brought up to light that this is in. Well, my work actually provided an alternative explanation. Where could these reports be coming from if this didn't happen?
并且，你发表了文章，你称之为揭露，这很有争议，你被这个女儿起诉了。你在TED演讲中谈到了科学家因工作而被起诉的令人不安的趋势，等等。那么你能谈谈这个吗？作为一名科学家，这意味着什么？文献中流传着一个由精神病学家发表的案例历史，你知道的，并且它被用作大规模压抑的新证据。
So my work showed that you could plant very rich, detailed false memories in the minds of people. It didn't mean that repressed memories did not exist. Repressed memories could still exist and false memories could still exist and false memories could still exist. But there really wasn't any strong, credible scientific support for this idea of massive repression, and yet so many families were destroyed by this, what I would say, unsupported claim. And going off on what you just said, you said you were at one point sued by a woman who claimed that her mother sexually abused her. And in this situation, you believed the mother was, they had not done this abuse.
这个案例历史是匿名的，所以是简·多伊（Jane Doe）和约翰·多伊（John Doe），妈妈镇，爸爸镇。在某个时候，我能够识别出多伊一家。一旦我找到了多伊一家的名字，我就可以查阅离婚档案，我找到了各种被这位精神病学家的陈述遗漏的信息。我找到了足够的信息让我相信，这个被指控的母亲——奇怪的是被指控性虐待的母亲——很有可能是无辜的。仅仅参与这项调查就让我陷入了极大的麻烦。
And, and you published, and you called it an expose, and it was controversial, and you were sued by this, by this daughter. And you talked about, in your TED talk, talked about the disturbing trend of scientists being sued or, you know, for their work. So can you speak a little bit about that? And what is that, as a scientist, what does that mean? There was a case history that was floating around in the literature, published by a psychiatrist. you know, sort of, and it was being used as the new proof of massive repression.
所以，是的，成年女儿确实起诉了我，起诉了我的合著者，起诉了我们发表这篇揭露报道的杂志以及其他人。最终，经过多年的诉讼，官司结束了。你在2016年赢得了约翰·马多克斯奖，该奖项旨在表彰那些倡导科学和证据但在这样做时可能面临困难或敌意的科学家。那么你能谈谈那个奖项，以及为什么你认为大声疾呼很重要，即使在困难的时候，即使你面临这些艰难的境地——比如你可能会被起诉，或者你的名字被点名并在泥潭中受辱，诸如此类的事情？
The case history was anonymous, so it was Jane Doe and John Doe, Momstown, Dads Town. And at some point, I was able to identify the Doe family. And once I found the Doe family, the name. of the family, then I could get into the divorce file and I found all kinds of information that had been left out of this psychiatrist's account. And I found enough information to convince me that that was a very strong likelihood that this accused mother, oddly the mother accused of sexual abuse, was probably innocent. And just being involved in this investigation got me in a lot of hot water.
嗯，我确实获得了约翰·马多克斯奖，我为此感到非常自豪，因为这是对在面对许多敌意时坚持科学的一种认可。这种敌意不仅仅来自诉讼，或者你知道的，还有其他一些个人，我猜他们觉得他们珍视的信念受到了攻击，并以各种令人不愉快的方式进行猛烈抨击。但我确实认为这很重要，因为，我的意思是，科学，你知道的，就是黑暗中的那一支蜡烛。而且，你知道的，它是将帮助这个世界变得更好的东西。所以，它需要被保护，尤其是在当今的气候下。你能谈谈关于你的研究出现的伦理问题以及你是如何回应的吗？
So, yes, the adult daughter did sue me and sue my co-author and the magazine where we published the expose and some other people. And eventually after years the litigation ended. And you won that in 2016, you won the John Maddox Prize, which recognizes the work of scientists who promote science and evidence but might face difficulty in doing so, or hostility. So can you talk a little bit about that and why you believe it's important to speak out, even when it's difficult, even when you face these tough situations where you might be sued or your name gets called out and dragged through the mud, that sort of thing?
我再重复一遍。你能谈谈关于你的研究出现的伦理问题以及这些年来你是如何回应的吗？伦理问题。嗯，我想一个伦理问题是，我在实验中所做的是否为了研究这个过程而在人们的大脑中植入虚假记忆。小型的虚假记忆，然后是大型的虚假记忆。所以有些人可能会认为这不是一件很有伦理道德的事情，但第一，
Well, I did win the John Maddox Prize, and I'm very proud of that, and because it is a recognition of standing up for science and in the face of a lot of hostility. And the hostility came not just from a lawsuit or, you know, but other individuals who were, feeling, I guess, that their cherished beliefs were being attacked and would lash out in all kinds of unpleasant ways. But I do think it's important because, I mean, science, you know, is that candle in the dark. And, you know, it is the thing that's going to help make this a better world. So, and it needs to be protected, especially in today's climate. Can you talk about the ethical questions that have come up about your research and how you've responded?
一切都经过大学人类受试者审查委员会的审查。很多人都做过同样种类的实验。据我所知，从来没有产生过任何不良影响。这是一个我认为已经帮助世界变得更美好的科学贡献。你曾谈到过植入虚假记忆的积极方面，比如它如何能以积极的方式被使用。你能对此做更多阐述，说明你所指的是什么吗？是的，我们在虚假记忆工作中的一个小转折是去观察
I'll say that again. Can you talk about the, can you speak to the ethical questions that have come up about your research and how you've responded over the years? The ethical questions. Well, I suppose one ethical question is whether, what I do in my experiments is plant false memories in the minds of people in order to study the process. bitty, false memories, and then great big ones. So some people might think that that's not a very ethical thing to do, but number one,
拥有虚假记忆的后果。如果我在你脑海中植入一个虚假记忆，它会有连锁反应吗？它会影响你之后的想法、之后的意图还是你之后的行为。我们现在已经证明，你可以植入一个虚假记忆，让你吃了某种食物生病了。你吃酸黄瓜、鸡蛋或草莓冰淇淋生病了，你就不想吃那么多这种食物了。我们植入过这样的虚假记忆，你喝伏特加饮品生病了，你对伏特加饮品的兴趣就没那么大了。我们做了相反的事情。植入了一个温暖的、模糊的记忆，即你喜欢一种健康的食物——芦笋。在我们的研究中，人们想要吃更多的芦笋。
everything is reviewed by the Human Subjects Review Committees at the universities. Many people have done these same kinds of experiments. As far as I know, there's never been an adverse effect. And it has been a scientific contribution that I think has. helped make the world a better place. And you've spoken about the positives of planting false numbers, like how it can be used in a positive way. Can you elaborate a little more on that and what you're, what you mean by that? Yes, one little twist in the false memory work that we did is to look
所以如果我们能控制人们的营养选择，也许帮助他们过上更健康的生活，也许这不是一件坏事。植入虚假记忆有什么危险吗，即使它是为了某种积极的事情，比如你试图吃得更健康、减肥或类似的事情？嗯，危险，我猜危险在于，
at the consequences of having a false memory. If I plan a false memory in you, does it have ripple effects? Does it affect your later thoughts or your later intentions or your your later behavior. And we've now shown that you can plan a false memory that you got sick eating a particular food. You got sick on pickles or eggs or strawberry ice cream, and you don't want to eat as much of that food. We've planted false memories that you got sick drinking a vodka drink and you're not as interested in a vodka drink. We've done the opposite. Planted a warm, fuzzy memory that you loved a healthy food, asparagus. in our study, and people want to eat more asparagus.
一些邪恶的不法分子可能会把这种思维技术拿去用于某种不良用途。就像我们现在可以制造核弹并将其用于不良用途一样。你能谈谈你的研究对刑法广泛的影响吗？我认为我和许多其他人对人类记忆、目击者证词、犯罪目击者和受害者的记忆所做的工作，对法律系统产生了一些影响。科学研究揭示了一些我们可以称之为最佳实践的东西，这些实践已经在许多司法管辖区得到实施，因此当执法人员和法律系统成员与参与法律案件的人互动时，他们能从人们那里获得最准确、最完整的信息，并且我们不会错误地判处没有犯罪的人有罪。所以我看到了一些巨大的影响。我们有什么办法可以预防虚假记忆或增强我们的记忆吗？哦，你知道的，如果你警告人们，可能会有人试图误导他们或欺骗他们，他们可以暂时保护自己，
So if we can control people's nutritional selections and maybe help them live a healthier life, maybe that's not a bad thing to do. Is there any dangers to planning false memories, even if it is for something positive, like you're trying to eat healthier, lose weight, or something like that? Well, the danger, I guess the danger,
并挡开误导信息。问题是，人们在生活中行走时，这些警告并没有摆在他们意识的最前沿。因此，我们需要寻找其他方法来让人们保护自己。你能增强你的记忆吗？你能，你知道的，以确保也许你确实记住的信息更准确，或者这甚至可能吗？你可以做一些事情来增强你的记忆，通常两件简单的事情就是：在你经历某事的时候或者在派对上学习某人的名字的时候更加专注，然后是排练。当然，我们知道已知的最佳排练模式可以最大化
is that some evil nefarious people could take this mine technology and put it to some bad use. Just the way we can build a nuclear bomb now and put it to some bad use. Can you talk about the broad implications of your research on criminal law? I think that the work that I and many other people have done on human memory, eyewitness test, testimony, the memory of witnesses and victims to crimes, has had some impact on the legal system. The scientific studies have revealed something that we might call best practices that have been implemented in a number of jurisdictions so that when law enforcement and members of the legal system interact with people who are involved in legal cases, they get the most accurate.
人们记住信息的可能性，正如我们谈到为你的TED演讲做准备时一样，你说你花了许多个月的时间来准备背诵一个16分钟的演讲。所以背诵那么长一段东西并增强记忆是一项繁重的工作。我的意思是，你知道的，当我被邀请在TED Global做TED演讲时，我已经教书几十万年……不，几十年了。所以这将是一场在台下可能有一千名观众面前的演讲，然后它会发布在TED网站上，
and complete information from people, and we aren't wrongly convicting people of crimes they didn't do. So I see some great impact there. Is there anything we can do to prevent against false memories or to enhance our memories? Oh, you know, if you warn people that somebody might be trying to mislead them or fool them, they can momentarily protect themselves
并被翻译成不知道多少种语言。所以确切的措辞是其中的一部分。你必须把它背下来。这实际上花了我大约三个月的时间，你知道的，通过练习、对着镜子说话、对着树说话来把它掌握下来。我使用了作为一名记忆科学家所学到的一些技巧，比如轨迹法。所以即使已经过去五年了，我现在也可以把演讲做给你听。你刚才说的是什么方法？我的意思是，这显然是重复。不，轨迹法涉及获取你想要记住的一块材料
and kind of fend off the mislead them. information. The problem is that people don't walk around in life with those warnings at the forefront of their consciousness. And so we're going to need to find some other ways of getting people to protect themselves. And can you enhance your memory? Can you, you know, to ensure that maybe the information you do remember is more accurate, or is it even possible? There are things you can do to enhance your memory for usually two simple things are just to pay better attention at the time you're being experiencing something or learning somebody's name at a party for example and then rehearsal and certainly we know the best patterns of rehearsal that are known to maximize the
并把它放在一个地方，比方说，在你家里，然后下一块放在另一个地方，再下一块放在另一个地方。然后你在脑海中穿过你的家，看到这些块。例如，我想告诉你一个我参与过的关于一个名叫史蒂夫·蒂图斯（Steve Titus）的男人的案子。蒂图斯是一位餐厅经理，有一天他被指控犯下了可怕的罪行。所以我记得那是因为我走到我的前门，那里有史蒂夫·蒂图斯。好的，告诉他们关于蒂图斯的事。然后我走进我的房子，这里有一幅肖像，是我嫁给她儿子时我婆婆画的。
likelihood that people will remember the information just as we spoke about about prepping for your TED talk, he said you had, it took a many months to prep for memorizing a 16 minute talk. So it's a lot of work to do you memorize something that long and to enhance your memory. I mean, you know, I'd been teaching for decades when I was invited
我看着，告诉他们关于你的事，你知道的。然后这里有一些松果。那是被诬告的人。告诉他们关于被诬告的人的事。因此，在穿过一个你已经放置了需要记住的内容块的熟悉地点时，你可以掌握它。这太迷人了。我绝对需要提高那项技能。如果你……有一本极其精彩的书叫做《与爱因斯坦漫步》，它描述了整个方法。这真的是一本很棒的通俗书。太棒了。好的，非常感谢你加入我们，洛夫图斯博士。我非常感谢你今天抽出时间。我的荣幸。《心理学谈话》是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包含其他精彩的播客，例如关于最新和最激动人心的心理学研究进展的《APA期刊对话》以及关于心理学实践的《进度记录》。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或你获取播客的任何地方找到我们的播客。你也可以访问speakingofpsychology.org，找到更多关于我们讨论主题的剧集和资源。我是主持人凯特琳·卢娜，代表美国心理学协会。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
to do a TED talk at TED Global. And so this was going to be a talk in front of maybe a thousand people in the audience and then it would go out on the TED website and it would
去 TED Global 做一场 TED 演讲。这场演讲的观众大约有一千人，之后还会发布到 TED 网站上，而且会被
be translated into who knows how many languages. So the exact wording was part of it. And you have to memorize it. And it actually took me about three months to, you know, practicing and talking to the mirror and talking to trees to get it down. And I used a few tricks that I'd learned as a memory scientist, like the method of loci. And so I could even give you the talk right now, even though it's been five years. What are some of those methods, you said? I mean, it's obviously repetition. No, the method of LOSI involves taking a chunk of material that you want to remember
翻译成不知道多少种语言。所以确切的措辞是其中一部分。而且你必须把它背下来。我实际上花了大约三个月的时间，你知道的，通过练习、对着镜子说话以及对着树说话来把它练熟。我用了一些作为记忆科学家学到的技巧，比如记忆宫殿法。所以即使已经过去五年了，我现在甚至还能把那场演讲背出来。你刚才说的是哪些方法？我的意思是，显然需要重复。不，记忆宫殿法包括把你想要记住的一大块材料
and placing it in a spot, let's say, in your home, and then the next chunk in another spot, and the next chunk in another spot. And then you take a mental walk through your home and you see the chunks. So, for example, I'd like to tell you about a case I worked on involving a man named Steve Titus. Titus was a restaurant manager, and one day he was accused of a horrible crime. So I remember that because I walked to my front door, and there is Steve Titus. Okay, tell them about Titus. And then I go into my house, and there's a portrait over here that my mother-in-law did when I married her son.
放在一个地方，比方说在你的家里，然后下一块放在另一个地方，再下一块放在另一个地方。接着你在脑海中漫步穿过你的家，就能看到这些材料块。举个例子，我想跟你讲一个我经手过的案子，涉及一个名叫史蒂夫·蒂塔斯的人。蒂塔斯是一名餐厅经理，有一天他被指控犯下了一起可怕的罪行。所以我是通过走到前门来记住这一点的，那里站着史蒂夫·蒂塔斯。好的，讲讲蒂塔斯的事。然后我走进屋子，那边有一幅我岳母在我嫁给她儿子时画的肖像画。
I look at, tell them about you, you know. Then there's some pine cones over here. That's the wrongly accused. Tell them about the wrongly accused. So in walking through a familiar location where you've placed chunks of what you need to remember, you can master it. That's fascinating. I definitely need to work on that skill.
我看着它，就想到了“讲讲关于你的事”。然后这里有一些松果。那是“被冤枉的人”。“讲讲关于被冤枉的人的事”。所以，通过在熟悉的地方漫步，并在那里放置你需要记住的材料块，你就能掌握它。太迷人了。我绝对需要锻炼一下这项技能。
Well, if you, there's a fabulous book called Moonwalking with Einstein that, that a, that, a that describes this whole method. It's really a great popular book. That's wonderful. Well, thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Lofdes. I really appreciate your time today. My pleasure. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts like APA journals dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also visit speaking of psychology.org to find more episodes and resources on the topics we discuss. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna, for the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
嗯，如果你……有一本非常棒的书叫《与爱因斯坦月球漫步》，里面详细描述了这种方法。这真是一本很棒的畅销书。太棒了。好的，非常感谢您加入我们的节目，洛夫图斯博士。非常感谢您今天抽出时间。不客气。《心理学对话》是美国心理学协会（APA）播客网络的一部分，其中还包括其他优秀的播客，例如探讨最新、最激动人心的心理学研究进展的《APA期刊对话》以及关于心理学实践的《进展手记》。你可以在 iTunes、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们的播客。你也可以访问 speaking of psychology.org，查找关于我们讨论主题的更多剧集和资源。我是主持人凯特琳·卢娜，代表美国心理学协会。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。